I'm Alice Markham this is prey my
taxidermy studio in downtown Los Angeles
everything I work on dies of natural
causes
I love animals and I love making them
last forever so today we're going to
teach vegans how to mount ducklings as
taxidermy I'm siggy and I've been vegan
since moving to LA about five years I'm
Nick I've been vegetarian for about ten
years and being in for six months my
name is Morgan and I've been vegan for
about a year and a half I'm very nervous
pretty nervous I'm feeling embarrassed
at how nervous I am it's just kind of
kind of creepy like I'm imagining the
worst worst possible scenarios I'm here
oh man is like a bag of ducklings these
are going to be your specimens all right
so we're gonna take this in three parts
today first we're going to be kind of
deconstructing our ducklings we're gonna
be taking them apart skinning them then
we're gonna be cleaning that skin so
it's not attractive to like pests and
things and then we're gonna be
essentially putting them back together
to look like little cute ducklings
so do you want to watch me make my first
incision and then I'm gonna ask you to
make yours I start at the top of the
chest and this scalpel is super sharp so
I just I can go real lightly I just
realize I'm gonna take off my watch for
this okay just slide it down perfect I
got a little bit lightheaded for a
second well just remember I can't get
much worse because they're already dead
apparently I'm good at this which is a
little bit frightening but I guess you
never know what your talents are until
you try them well the good news is we're
about to cut the bodies off the bad news
is we're not quite done with them so I'm
gonna have you go ahead and snip the
neck right about there oh I don't know
if I can watch this 1 2 3 oh how do you
remove some things innards from its neck
and like a respectable way like
respectful ways they're like I'm not
maybe just cross yourself I'm not sure
no Jesus doesn't need to come into this
mmm Oh weird oh man that felt weird
inside of me go big or go home
good good job you guys I'm definitely
glad that I know what the inside of the
bird looks like what the end that he
looks like I feel wiser even if I don't
feel happy so we're gonna be cleaning
them a little more you guys need to have
wire brushes and there's like a big in
and a small end we're hoping to use the
small end you ever go like pick up
roadkill and ranan only only for the
museum I'm about to remove the eyeball
from the bird which I've been told
resembles a blueberry right now we're
tossing the eyeballs and scrap bits of
flesh in the meat bag they're gonna
become little birds in here again I'm
gonna have you get them under the water
and then we're gonna turn their skulls
right side out pop it right through nice
and slow
and it kind of becomes a little duckling
again now we're gonna take our soap with
our picture of our little duckling on it
Kiki and we're gonna set these guys up
see much said yours up yeah get it all
over on the inside and on the outside
nice and suds so weird what we're gonna
do now is we're gonna fill the head and
the eye orbits with the clay so I just
pop it in there and I pull it kind of
flush have a sip of coffee my eyeballs
see how there's wires coming out the
bottoms of the legs they go up into the
little bodies we're gonna put in so
first we're just gonna run wires up
through the bottom of the feet and we're
gonna go just along our bones okay so
we're just kind of loosely tying it to
there okay I feel like I'm a little
desensitized there's also no more like
blood and guts and gore and I still have
no idea how it's gonna end up being
anything cuz it looks like this I know
so me and Madison are gonna put in your
bodies and wire them and then we're
gonna start sewing maybe the game's just
not getting feather stuck in our
stitches and again just dead like a
delicate delicate and it doesn't need to
be tight all right so we're gonna fluff
your bird this dust is called chinchilla
dust or chinchilla fluff basically it's
gonna help us fluff out our little
duckling and make him look happy again
oh he's getting fluffier we're gonna
turn on the blow-dryer and this is like
where the magic happens awesome so let's
get his little head right way around and
we're gonna get him on here here is my
completed but she looks much happier
than he did an hour ago I was really
freaked out when I first got here and
when we started doing this but I'm
surprised at how the day kind of
progressed it was really very
educational
and actually more fun than I thought it
was gonna be I like the appreciation
that I got for her for life doing this
it was a very surprisingly intimate
experience I think it's kind of
interesting and educational and
I'm not sure that veganism and taxidermy
are kind of mutually exclusive I think a
lot of the conversation today was about
how there's a way to you know treat
animals really well it's nice to see
something that had died suddenly kind of
reanimated I started using the word cute
to describe this which I didn't think
was going to be the case now I can say
like um maybe I'm vegan approved maybe
not I don't know